and by the way your greatest role ever
is when you do your JD impression Ryan
[Music]
come on come on
I want to just go on record
you're still angry with him aren't you
yeah
you feel JD should be grateful to you
for because you do an Impressions nice
ah it's just you know I don't know
[Music]
but I know you're upset with JD because
he never thanked you for doing an
impression of him at the birthday show
you still have results yes I did you did
thank him
you said that to me JD yeah after
after my last appearance
I don't know I don't remember that but I
don't know what's going on with you two
I hope you work it out I went to go
visit him before I came on the show you
did and he was masturbating in his
little cubicle what'd you say to him did
you do your impression when you talked
to him
what are you doing there what
you're not supposed to masturbate like
this like you're rolling it use one hand
like a man like
Brian Cranston an excellent actor he
loves it he loves it and he loves JD and
he loves doing an impression of JD